the Comedy Store would like you to know
that the views and opinions expressed on
this podcast are strictly those of the
speakers or authors and do not
necessarily reflect or represent the
views and opinions held by the Comedy
Store and its affiliates
this is the Comedy Store podcast I'm
Eleanor carrion that is not Rick Ingram
yeah I do sir we can pretend but he
could be a child or whatever you guys
want me to be
who doesn't shut the [ __ ] up and never
come down here he doesn't even pay
attention to the board he [ __ ] up Greg
Fitzsimmons now he has a girlfriend so
we have to deal with that we recorded
another comment it didn't come out now
he's like I'm on the road all the time
I'm a big [ __ ] comic you know to be
fair the episodes I get [ __ ] up are
the ones where I can't be here when I
write here they all work right but you
you know is that loud enough yeah it's
good Oh are you pretending you're doing
something as a producer I think core is
more of a producer than you we are here
with the great court McGowan producer
yeah I don't know well obviously you do
your own podcast correct oh yeah I do
what's the name of your podcast the name
of our podcast is in sensitivity
training and oh yeah because if you do
something that your bartnick it's
insensitive he's not he's not edgy he's
the edge you call man Edgar the edge
well I don't most of the other comics do
I call mat agar they called the edge the
edge yeah what I've never heard anyone
call does he become edgy no Neil and
Jeff Danish when they would host they
would bring him up as the I could see
someone calling him the bottom he looks
like he looks like some dudes bottom
he's going to get raped repeatedly right
he's not the raper no he's rapist the
rapey I mean to say someone wouldn't do
well in prison he would do very well in
prison he he'd have a [ __ ] ton of
cigarettes
he'd haven't made you know I mean it's
very good as Rick are you were
oh you want me to carry the podcast yes
I mean this is opening for Polly's
really very also open for the great
court McGowan once we're a comedy store
yes yeah he didn't show up one I missed
the show for my favorite first time did
you really miss him it was my first I
want you to know that's the first time
and only time I've missed a show I
apologize to court as well as the
world-famous Comedy Store and I felt
very guilty so what happened was if it
doesn't include head it doesn't count it
was no sexual context involved Emily
asked me to court asked me to do it and
then Emily asked me to it of course I
jumped at the opportunity was excited to
do it
then after I agreed to do it air B&B
scheduled this such a boring story they
scheduled an you know idea Saturday
morning so I drove from La Jolla
saft er the show Friday night back to LA
then I tried to fit in this meeting then
I drove back but there's four hours of
traffic and I came ten minutes late
right when Brenton was on stage I got
mad minutes late minutes but you know
what in all fairness I wasn't I wasn't
really pissed off at all no I wasn't I
felt bad for him he missed a spot the
show never not once I have that makes me
feeling worse yeah thank God the
carrier's back you're wrong
I didn't mean care a bit Rick we say you
carry what we could do is we could just
have him come in and I'll edit this
little segment out and people won't even
know if they'll think Rick was there the
whole time that's how good I was oh I
know it's not because we heard it he
just photoshop's another face and that's
all it is
we were talking about how he missed a
show at La Jolla due to traffic he
missed an entire show yeah yeah he was
the LCA efficiency and any missed it but
Wow the only person but Ryan was pissed
yeah Ryan was really pissed off I wasn't
really I I didn't really
he's gonna expect that to happen in La
Jolla I mean there is [ __ ] ton of
traffic well they have a condo where
people stay overnight it was the
Saturday show yeah Friday show it was a
Saturday show yeah cuz I drove back to
LA Friday night and then tried to drive
back for the Saturday the other side of
the why I don't deserve to be bullied I
deserve you guys's respect bullying me
just like Joey's bully John kept
Parrilla Comedy Store stories in the
middle of a huge feud yeah start that
are you get in the middle of it because
I feel like you have the clout Kerry I
do I do like that this tripod is 50
times the size of the camera though it
looks like it looks like you've got this
tripod holding a paper clip so what
happened with the show Who am seated did
they just put up a lot yeah we just had
one of the guys MC and then Brendan you
know I just I didn't think it was fair
that since Ari [ __ ] up and didn't make
his MC spot that right that Brendan
should have to go on first person
Brendan Biddle co o Brenton yeah and the
other thing well I called Brenton I'm so
sorry he goes no it's no problem but
then we didn't clear it with Ryan in
court we just well Brenda didn't say
anything till like right minutes before
the it's so different of you are you're
usually so you know professional I think
you're being sarcastic but I answer I
will say I will say that the the three
shows he did show up for he did a fine
job but so Brenton didn't have to host I
mean those guys down there are all
comics the door ya mean our nation at
least be at our ease because they're
really good down there just for making
drinks and I should also say I've never
seen already do comedy ever not yet I
have yeah what do you think honest
opinion just give us a little critique
III I'm gonna say very funny yeah I mean
I shouldn't say I watch him I could hear
him when I was in the green room playing
Angry Birds
I don't watch any more and I think it's
from years of waiting tables in that
showroom I cannot you know what's funny
is is recently I started watching again
I did I have I haven't in years
yeah it's just cuz and it's mostly
because you've seen the same people
especially being here as long as we've
been here yeah watch hasn't been here
for a long it's watching reruns even the
ones you like it's like I've seen this
happen yeah and it's and it's like I've
been on the road with a lot of these
guys so I've seen the although I watched
holtzman on Saturday night and that's
never there's nothing rehearse normal
about the lady got mad and stormed out
or was that Friday night that was I did
not I asked him I said Brian do you ever
record your sets because there's some
gems that you just throw out there that
I never see or hear again and he was
like I can't do that that would make me
learn something but yeah so there's some
that you can watch for me yes but I
think phone working in that room so long
like when I first got here I watched it
all the time and then yeah yeah and I
you learn what works learn what doesn't
work but I think at a certain point at
least for me it was like I couldn't
watch it because I don't want especially
exactly I don't want to Robin Williams
people by access I'm proud working some
on and some joke I heard and didn't
think about comes in comes into my head
and then it's like yeah well you know
Rick's doing so and so's bit oh so and I
think but you know I think that's
interesting because there is so many now
especially especially today there's so
many comics and there's so many
different you know you're seeing it all
in YouTube or you're seeing it all
wherever at Twitter or whatever the [ __ ]
it is right and I think there's a lot of
premises that that are gonna get crossed
that's just that's just the way it's
been it's just the way it's gonna happen
but I think as long as you're true to
yourself which you are I mean you're
you're doing your own thing you do your
own thing yeah and it's like and I and I
come from my umph as long as you're
being you coming from you
yeah it's gonna be different it made you
know there's never gonna be the same
it's not gonna be the same yeah I mean
none of us are you know I mean there are
people that do do that
you're not mentioning any names but I
mean there's there's people that do do
word-for-word yeah you know they do take
it pretty much word-for-word maybe put a
little twist on it maybe and and and
those are the ones that it's like it's
sad yeah called out cuz someone they
will there's a lot of people who just
like being combative in our industry so
at some point someone's gonna call them
out I mean they absolutely do it and so
I think it's like and there's not there
could be nothing more embarrassing than
to be at some places someone come up and
go dude that's so and so's yeah oh you
just got to look like a [ __ ] [ __ ] at
that point I've literally heard a young
comic do in La Jolla it was he was one
of the guys coming down open he was
doing I rare his bit about he has a
friend that's a brain surgeon and his
burner of his brain surgeon friend was
like you know I wish I could be funny
like you that's Dom's yeah you've heard
that yeah I know I could be funny like
you and then Dom was like really like
you're you're branch
you're a brain surgeon you could be
funny a little he's like I can't do
brain surgery a little and this kid was
doing it he was 25 years old and I
thought
like that's the thing was is John
Barrera is his brain surgeon the thing
is he's 25 he doesn't have a friend old
enough to be a brain surgeon yet he's
not at that point so how are you using
that
how is that real to you yeah I mean it
was so weird to me I remember I remember
there was a comic that came in and we
won't me I won't mention names but he's
a good guy he's not gonna play our dirty
kill yeah he was doing Freddy sotto oh
it's a constant and he was doing and I
was just like you can't [ __ ] I mean it's
especially unholy sauce I will say that
specifically in this house that guy who
you're talking about when he came here
he did not realize how much of this
house is Freddy Soto's and so all the
guys got together and said hey you
cannot do that and then he was like oh
I'm not and he denied it for a little
bit and then he changed his tune and
completely stopped yeah so well again
yeah but you should never do it I'm not
saying it makes it right I just might
have gone on the road confronted in his
defense he might have gone on the road
with Michael wheels Parise this is true
and he got done the road to paying money
you got a that is true wheels would give
young comics that advice Jesus even what
was great about those that he would
suggest from his personal opinion who he
felt material you should do just like go
out there and just do anyone's it was
like would be you know would be good for
you
Wow do you know any bill behind it you
seem kind of angry too I should do we
should be angry
perfect for you all right
yeah I don't know how this works great
swordfish you have it yeah that's funny
I went to his uh he had a Christmas
party one year it was like maybe my
second or third year in LA and I just
decided you know I couldn't afford to go
home or whatever so wheels invited me to
his place he said he was doing a
Christmas Eve thing at that point he was
he was pretending that Luca Poloncarz
place like a block away from the Comedy
Store was his place that's worse and I
was just like how do you afford this and
then I year and half later Luke is like
oh yeah you've been to my place I was
like well no I've been to wheels he's
like yeah wheel stays at my place I fell
for another parisi yes I went down there
and made a bunch of steaks and fish and
it was really who's delicious I was like
whoa we also can actually and then at
once people started handing out like
they were swapping xanaxes and I was
just like well this is [ __ ] Hollywood
party man this is how they do it just
like the word it's good it's good it
takes the edge off an Eightball
I will tell you that I think you at one
time when I was in Alaska not with
wheels different time when I was there
it is easy and someone was like hey you
want a xanax I'm like what does it do
they like just make you have more fun
I'm like whatever I'm sorry like six
beers in so I took it
oh good night Susie yeah oh [ __ ] yeah
you're hammered it that I I think I was
up for another two and a half three
hours hanging out don't remember any
he's gonna say to you this whole
blackout lockout
thirty minutes of taking it just like
people oh yeah you're pretty crazy last
night like value much the valium used to
make me blackout that's never did valium
did I used to because I used I there was
a time when I party yeah it's been a
while now but yeah and but I used to do
I used to do a ton of I used to a lot of
blow so you it get me a little edgy
when you do a lot of it yeah and so I
used to try to kind of even the keel
even if you a little bit so I would do
like you know vicodin or xanax or you
know some of these other ones but but I
couldn't do valium they always it was
like blackout City I mean yeah funny and
I used to drive so I you know I know
in ableism went viral but you would
drive coked up oh yeah there's nothing
wrong with driving coked up it was like
it's the thirty other drinks yeah it's
the whiskey you had one of my exes you
wouldn't get a license because he was
afraid to drive like he preferred to
party so he was like I'll just take
[ __ ] cabs but I'm not stopping
partying know why you suggested he was a
responsible drug addict if you will I
was pretty responsible I used to keep my
coke in in a metal hide-a-key underneath
inside the gas tank container it's a
good spot nobody really knows it's there
you know now I do I knew a new a dude in
college we would eat mushrooms or
whatever sometimes and I know a guy who
would he didn't like mushrooms he would
always take acid and so he knew a guy
who always had acid and he would take
three or four hits and just be out of
his mind
yeah let me be hanging out with them and
be like oh man he's bi ready to get
crazy he'd be like alright I'm gonna go
back what do you mean he's like I'm just
starting to trip so I'm gonna get out of
here wait that's when you're you were
waiting to start tripping and then he
would just drive like 40 minutes to
Kansas City never had any issues I I
wouldn't make it out of the parking lot
if I was hallucinating I went to when I
was in college we went to see the who
play in 1982 this was
this was their final tour okay their
first first of many fortunately finally
yeah bit but this was 1982 and there was
like 11 of us that we we started in
Stillwater Oklahoma and we were driving
to Dallas Texas which normally is about
about a four-hour drive maybe okay you
know on the outside maybe four hours
that's if you're driving or you know
normal speed limits then we're probably
about 55 55 yeah whatever it was so I
mean it's normally about a four-hour
drive yeah and and as and we left at
like 6:00 in the morning
and we got down there I think about
seven o'clock the next night because we
all decided we go over driving it's only
gonna take four hours let's just we got
in the car we go let's just eat acid now
we've got more assets will be more acid
when we get there and we were I mean I
remember like being somewhere on i-35
between Dallas and Oklahoma City at like
you know the sun's coming up and we're
playing frisbee on the interstate like
you know I just [ __ ] tripping our
balls up but a great concert though we
checked into a la quinta in everybody
showered yeah all class we had two rooms
for like 11 people and he took turns
showering we all showered and dropped
now hit acid went to the show had a
[ __ ] phenomenal time it was great
concert Wow very much
Quinta that I stayed at was in Chicago
when they had that riddles comedy club
yeah so rent is easy and I went and we
were we they got us rooms at the La
Quinta and we pulled up and is like in
South Chicago so it's like not the nice
part of Chicago yeah we pulled up and
there was there was two black dudes and
their pit bulls were just fighting like
in the grass right in front of the place
I'm like this is where we're staying
he's like I'm sure it's fine we go in
and a large black lady who's working on
thing and she kind of gave us like what
are you here for and we sell we're
comedians at the comedy club she said
something to the effect of we didn't
look old enough to be comedian I think
we were just trying to trigger a be
giving us the comedian's room right so
she gave us our room keys and we went to
our rooms and I remember Steve's room
went to the what appeared to be the
nicer area of the hotel and mine was
down like the hallway they have like the
blinking rape lights yeah going no one
fix these so I go into my room and I
kind of look around it's like the air
conditioning unit is like detached from
the wall and there's like a good three
inches of space for you can just see
into the wall yeah I was like oh this is
good and I walked into the bathroom and
there was just poop all over the doorway
[ __ ] I get on the phone and I call away
she's like yeah I'm like yeah I just
checked in and there's pubes all over
the floor she's like this what
there's pubes pubes yeah it looks like
the cleaning lady came in clean the room
and then shaved her pubes in the
bathroom oh you don't have to get a
different room yeah thanks so that's
what I think of when I think of LaQuinta
I was I was getting so working the desk
yeah I was glad when I was caddying on
the PGA Tour we stuff staying shitty huh
you and your caddies you see your towels
so I was in Tucson Arizona one time and
I checked into this Red Roof Inn nice
hotel yeah a nice hotel in this money
and this is one of those like because
you do it on like Priceline you know
whatever sorry but I'd done it through
Expedia and it was like there was like
$79.99 at night whatever was it wasn't
it wasn't that expensive and so I go in
the room I open the door and there's
food chocolate and food stuck in the air
conditioner right like that there's it's
like it's stinks out [ __ ] stinks in
there I walk in the bathroom someone had
taken a [ __ ] and not even flushed it it
was sitting in the [ __ ] toilet this
[ __ ] was sitting in the toilet this room
is clean and and I literally go back
downstairs and I go and I was going to
dinner with the guy was caddying for I
go I'm going to dinner I go either that
either you get me a new [ __ ] or
either you like going and bleach that
room
yeah I'm clean that [ __ ] disgusting
[ __ ] up cuz I already paid for it so
I was like there's you know how much I
could do
yeah and then I and then and then so I
literally went to dinner I came back
there's a different person at desk I
walked in it was the same [ __ ] thing
and I walked back downstairs and I I
called [ __ ] Expedia and I was like I
am not paying for this [ __ ] place and
I told the person and and they go what
are you talking about it's not him I go
let's go let's go yeah they go what I go
let's go look at the room and they go
well I can't leave Michael let's go look
I was thought no one else is checking
into the Red Room yeah and we walked in
and the person was like throwing up was
like throwing up in her mouth she was
like that give you another rumor they
they were offer to give me another room
and I said I'm not I would not stay I
can't stay in this hotel if this room's
like this god only knows god only knows
what has happened in the other rooms
which is fine by me I mean yeah sleeping
on caution tape like this is weird
we were in I think was either a Hilton
or a Hyatt and Wichita what we were
doing I was doing the loony bin with
Pauly and so Pauly would make you share
rooms with either the other comic if he
brought one or not and I'd have to share
a room with the bodyguard yeah or
whoever else was just at the hotel with
that guy we know sharing room with the
bodyguard and then we walked in after
the show one night and there's a pretty
cute girl working the desk so Terrell
went over and started spitting game at
her and whatever it was then he he comes
up like a minute two minutes later he's
like hey I talked that girl and giving
me a room and I was like oh that's sweet
he's like yeah yes I'm down the hall
come down we'll smoke so I went down to
his room whenever we went down there to
go get high and we walk in he's checking
out oh yeah this room's nice man way
better view and it's just like a view of
instead of the highway it was like a
view of some woods or something tree
yeah a tree so we go in there and then
he walks in just go
hell no I'm like what what he's like
someone [ __ ] in the tub the tub and then
they drained the tub and it made it down
to the drain but there's like still just
half the turd this is spectacular down
try to explain to the girl she's like
it's what it's like someone [ __ ] in the
tub then they tried to just drain the
tub like the [ __ ] was gonna go down the
little holes she was like do you want a
different room hell yeah I was like dude
he didn't even pay for it but her face
was just like what if this guy just [ __ ]
yeah I'm gonna give you what I'll give
you the last I was I was staying I went
to do this tournament on the tour we
were at Endicott New York which is like
in northern or upstate or [ __ ] just
[ __ ] yeah there's nothing up there
and close to Canada yeah and all the car
and all the Caddy stea cuz we don't have
to rent cars if you have to drive to the
core so there's this the one where the
the golf course is right across the
street from this like hotel slash motel
yeah and all the caddies like Oh bro
we're all gonna stay there it's all
great everyone rooms does somebody only
cost you like like 45 a night it's great
you know blah blah blah I'm like okay
cool you know and so we check into this
thing and and it's it's a [ __ ]
it's Israel I mean it's it's a [ __ ]
[ __ ] it's worse than a motel 6 it's
this thing I don't even remember the
name of but it's a [ __ ] hotel yeah it
only gets people because of location and
it's like and the only in it's up in the
only time it's only time it's busiest
during that week of the tournament right
because the tournaments right across the
street so so I'm like all right whatever
we'll [ __ ] just will barrel it out
this week no big [ __ ] deal we stay in
this thing well I gotta take a shower
there's like no shower pressure I mean
the water just like a cat pissing on you
know so I go down to play playing I was
like I was like what the [ __ ] up with
that water pressure there like water
barely comes out of the sink to [ __ ]
brush your teeth and she's like and all
the caddy started complaining so she
calls a plumber
the plumber a plumber comes there and
these pipes are from like 1950 and he
unplugs the pipe what happens is the
entire place
the water pressure suddenly the water
pressure goes and every everything is
black water like I mean it's like the
water is like black straight slug like
just sludge and so and so they everyone
I mean like you would flush your toilet
and sludge would go down and sludge and
so the guys like and I I found the the
[ __ ] plumber and he goes just turn
your water on a let it run so I like
went to caddy that they went to do a
practice round so like 9:00 in the
morning I turned all the hot and cold
water on in the shower and in the sink
and the tub and everything and then left
for like six hours and I came back and
my water was [ __ ] career clear and
all the other caddies every [ __ ] room
is still got sludge I charge them all
five bucks apiece to shower in a [ __ ]
room made the whole week up gorget water
like because I wasn't ready to flood
this room okay I'm gonna go back to the
comedy store stuff what year did you
start here like stand-up I guess started
here in 2002 stand up yeah I started
when you started to instant yeah I
started doing stand-up in 2002 I started
with Adam Barnard I did Sunday nights I
took Adam Bernhardt's class yeah yeah
yeah well I did it before I did it
before you begin yeah and then and I did
his class and then if you did his class
you got to you know showcase on a Sunday
night whatever and then he liked me so
he was like do why don't you come do
Sunday nights you set up the candles
yeah and you get and you get like five
minutes six minutes a night right so I
started doing Sunday nights I did Sunday
nights for about probably about a year
yeah you know and but do other open
mikes you know ice Duke our gulch with
[ __ ] a painter and you know you know
all those guys
yeah what's the place called making our
Gulch there was some [ __ ] restaurant at
Geragos and that's when they had the
blue the brew house through house in
Westwood yeah Westwood was another one
and there was Adam Hunter was running it
at that point I don't know if yeah Adam
kind of ran it but it was kind of like
different people did it so it was like
but you could get up there
that wasn't got a weekly I got a weekly
spot here which was great and then I get
thrown on a little show every now and
then and this is back when Duncan was
here yeah you know so and then I started
my own what my own show on Wednesday
nights you know I did with Paul Hughes
Paul Hewson we started as a rock comedy
thing that was we used to call it PCP
comedy oh yeah yeah yeah so we did PCP
comedy up there and what we did
Wednesdays once a month where did you do
it here in the belly room yeah yes we
did the belly room on a Wednesday night
and he was you know he'd been doing
comedy for a while so he was good
friends with cook and some of those
other guys so we would get like we'd get
great I used to get great crowds and so
we built this show up to be like this
great show in like a year and this was
about the time they were doing minding
the store
and so Paul II was kind of getting a
little more involved and so we had these
I mean we had these it's just tons of
hot chicks used to come to this show
yeah yeah at the club the story they
were filming like 2004-2005 yeah well
this was like this quit because of it
yeah this was like right this was like
right before they started filming it
okay so it was right but but Paulie was
here more you know back then but they so
it was like I think it was 2003 we
started doing main room shows and we
partnered with Jay Davis was that the
rock that was rock oh okay so that's
what we started doing that show was
[ __ ] it makes so much money yeah but
we used to pack that [ __ ] room and it
was too packed the main room and you
know we have I remember one night we had
Harlan Williams Dane Cook Sarah
Silverman
I'm trying to think we had the other guy
that I loved that passed away it'll come
to me nice looking guy from Oakland
can't think of what he passed away from
Mulaney maybe Mitch Mulaney not was
Mitch Mulaney yeah we hadn't but we
never had Mitch Mulaney on that we had
him upstairs but we never had him down
in the in the in that main room then
maybe that's why I saw him yeah he's the
what he passed away right yeah yeah it
was really funny yeah he was a really
funny it was silly and he was never in
the main room I feel like I remember
standing at the door and I thought oh
good that guy's here he was funny and
I'd never seen him yeah in our regular
line oh yeah well we ended up puttin it
up happening was is we started when we
were doing the rooms upstairs in the
bedroom I had a good good friend of mine
who ran all the nightclubs at the Palms
Hotel in Vegas yeah this guy Michael
Martin used to come to the shows you
know when he was in town and he and he
was always like he always like oh man
you should be doing these shows in Vegas
and I was like well you know let me know
and so we had one night we did the main
room and it was it was just an one of
those nights where I had gotten this is
back before everyone had all these I had
sponsors like I hadn't had a magazine
that sponsored it had all these
different people sponsors so they gave
us money and so we had step-and-repeat
walls we had all this stuff going on for
the main room and then Michael brought
George Maloof to the show no no and this
was a night where it was just packed to
the gills and after the show George came
up to me he goes I want to talk to you
about doing a show at the hotel and this
is when the poems was the biggest
[ __ ] it was the big yeah and so that
we did our show on Wednesday on Sunday
night we flew to Vegas and on Monday
morning we signed a deal with the Palms
to do that was then called The Hollywood
Comedy Tour oh so we would go there and
we would do a show once a month and we
started out in 2003 March of 2003 we did
our first show in Vegas
and then by March of 2004 or 2005 I
candid up getting Playboy as a sponsor
yeah so then we called the Playboy
Comedy Tour
you guys all shows yeah but we had it I
mean everybody did that show everybody
that was I mean Freddie Soto
yeah Freddie did the show Colin Quinn I
mean we had I miss I mean Daniel Tosh
before anybody knew who he was before
anybody news this fashions first
headline is the bastion regularly
everybody yeah we had all these people
would come in Bobcat Goldthwait did it I
mean I mean we had everybody do this
room and it was such a great room and it
was like a 225 seat room and you know I
did it for I did it for eight eight and
a half years Wow so and we went from
doing one song run yeah we did we
started doing once a month and by the
end of the the last three years there we
did every Thursday Friday Saturday every
week yeah and it was I mean you know we
had dice Jim Jefferies we had Jefferies
used to do it sweet
you know only person I didn't get to do
it was at our bure and those were the
two I really wanted like I really wanted
to get bird but burr was at the time it
was difficult to get yeah he was right
transition he was in that big transition
and he was getting he was doing well yes
he was doing well no I mean not as good
as he's doing now but he was still doing
really well but the money just triple
the money yeah and and I think at the
time they were trying to get you know
there was two plays there you could
either do this [ __ ] Club that you did 14
shows a week yeah or you could do that's
the only other time I've done Vegas was
that that [ __ ] improv at Harrah's yeah
or no a Laugh Factory or you know I've
had Brad Garrett tried you know and it's
like no no I was still yeah I didn't get
it yeah I wasn't around for that and
then but then by the time you know and
then the only other room there was
Mirage which was like was like you know
Jay Leno and Seinfeld
you know it was like the big one so we
were this like young [ __ ] thing and
it was so much [ __ ] fun
it was so much fun I mean I remember
Riggle was doing the show and I Robert
was doing it and like in the back like
was Lisa Lampanelli
who was doing the the
[ __ ] million the big right marinelli
was down to pearl which is 1500 seats
and wriggles in our room doing the show
lampanelli's they're watching and
sitting by behind her is Jimmy Kimmel
the [ __ ] that guy from the office I
can't remember his name
Gervase no the American the American
version that Steve Carell no the the guy
that's married to him away helps Emily
Blunt or whatever the actress in the
actress Jett [ __ ] can't think of his
name John
John Krasinski John Krasinski and his
wife now is the Emily Blunt so the three
of them are and they're dressed nice and
they like came in and to be you know for
the beginning of the show sat for the
show watched the show and [ __ ] you
know and left at the end it was like I
mean we'd have like I remember once flea
Anthony Kiedis and Sacha Baron Cohen
were at the show and Sacha Baron Cohen
you know not as Ali G and doesn't want
to be you know you can't [ __ ] talk to
him like you know and I mean I remember
Penn Jillette used to come to the show
and Penn Jillette would sit in the back
and he's such a big dude you know my god
and and I could see him and he would
never laugh he just didn't laugh stop it
never [ __ ] laugh and then he come
backstage he go it was a great show I
think Colin Quinn Toby's like he goes he
doesn't laugh he just doesn't laugh
that's so funny
how was Colin I called one of my
favorite he is probably one of my
favorite people there there's like
there's guys there that there there were
guys there that I had that I like I had
some of my favorites were like Patrice
O'Neal of course you know Patrice O'Neal
was one of those guys and Patrice was
there with Ian Edwards which was like
like what a great show I mean it's like
that's all that's black on black crime
yeah and and it was so fun and then you
had like like Robert Kelly oh you know
Robert Kelly would you know we'd do
everything to make him throw up because
you
he has this weird gag reflex so if you
show him something gross he will throw
up so we would just thought we were just
like he's so hard to not just try and do
okay that's all you do but she would do
stay that's the kind of [ __ ] we do all
the time you know Harlan Williams was
was there one time and Harlan's cousin's
one of the guys from what's the the the
band I can't think of the name of the
Canadian band
Barenaked Ladies I just asked a guy in
the crowd tonight if he was in the
Barenaked Ladies are you serious yeah
are you leading the Barenaked Ladies he
goes no but I am Canadian well you all
look the same
yeah any white guy we were there and me
and and Harland and his cousin were
sitting backstage and Shaun tweedily was
on stage and Shaun was I mean he wasn't
doing bad but he wasn't destroying right
you know and and we just know it
he's a funny comic and he doesn't mostly
improv stuff but anyways Shaun was on
stage and Harlan goes let's all walk
across the stage in our underwear and so
we like literally because there is a
place you could remember at the stage
you could walk from backstage you could
walk across the stage you could go get
off the stage and walk around to that
side door okay so we just like standing
there and Shauna's mid joke just just
talking to the crowd and the three of us
just nothing but our [ __ ] underwear
just start walking right across the back
as the crowd starts going crazy
Shaun thinks he's really fun this is the
joke is open all the time it was like it
was the funnest [ __ ] thing but what a
way to come up get into work with all
those guys because you would host or
open right yeah what host yeah I would
but that was the difference was he's
like I got lucky in the sense that you
know I had only been in comedy about a
year and a half you know when I got that
show and so I was still very green when
I was starting it but it but I got to do
comedy five times six times a week yeah
I got to get on stage and do five
yes a lot of people don't and I got real
lucky in that you know I got to do that
so when it came time to showcase here
like here I wasn't I didn't feel
uncomfortable you know and I'd done
movies in theatres and all that stuff
way bro oh my god yeah so I so presence
was already there wasn't uncomfortable
on stage so it didn't bother me to be on
stage it was just the material that
needed work I mean it still needs a lot
when I first remember seeing you I
didn't realize that you were new to
comedy I mean it was just like oh just
some guy just got to the comedy store or
whatever but you definitely I think I
was probably still doing impressions so
I don't think I was judging anyone else
by Will Ferrel act that I was putting
out there well it's funny because like I
had auditioned for MIT I I'd show keys
for mitzi once and and I feel really
lucky in the or I feel really lucky that
I was around when MIT is here absolutely
I feel like don't you feel like if if
nothing else if if you know tomorrow I
don't ever have another spot here I can
say my name is on that wall because I'm
Mitzi shore yeah [ __ ] all you guys yeah
you know that that you know got through
on the Tommy well I met she said she
liked your tape yeah it's like yeah it's
like yeah well the funny thing was is I
remember like she used to pass you she
would pass you not necessarily based on
where you were you know she saw
something she saw and she and she said
all right so and I remember I died
showcase for once she didn't even look
at me when I came off my name was just
crossed off and yeah because she would
sit in the back with her popcorn or
glass of wine with her names on the list
and if you want inch and if she and she
would just cross your name off
yeah and then a lot of times what would
happen was you would be up there and
other comics won't say who but that most
of them that didn't want that didn't
want to have other people passed would
come up and start talking too busy off
intentionally so that you couldn't you
couldn't showcase and so Luka
acha was a good friend of mine I known
Luka for a long time and I was up there
and he was working with Mitty driving
minutes he loved him yeah and so he sat
down next to me because don't worry
she's gonna watch her set yeah and I sat
down and some comic walked up and he
just [ __ ] shoved his head out of the
way and Luca goes get the [ __ ] out of
here and and she watched my set I had an
okay set it wasn't great you know but I
had an okay but she paid attention and
then when I walked out she looked at me
she goes do you want to get some spots
and I [ __ ] high five my ass all the
way down the [ __ ] hallway it's the
greatest feeling in the world
yeah but then but then what would happen
was she would give you a spot the next
week at nine o'clock yeah any or yeah
you would get one spot and then you
wouldn't get a spot for three months
yeah that's what she would do she'd give
you one no no she but but I heard later
what the part of the thing was and she
told me this once when I was sitting in
her office with her she said cuz I
wanted to see if you wanted it and it's
like so you would come so if you got
your spot that's to let you know you're
in and then you've got Sundays and
Mondays to come up here and work right
because we did it both night Sunday
Monday and back then nobody wanted to go
up on Sunday money cuz mitzi was here
yeah so you could there's no crowd
there's no crowd so you could go up
every Sunday and Monday and do ten
minutes literally walk in the door like
you're [ __ ] louis c.k and walk on
yeah and walk on stage like you would
walk in and they go you're next yeah you
want to go up you're next yeah I was
getting the same treatment yeah because
we were passed a lot of pretty close to
the same time yeah yeah for sure yeah I
got passed in end of 2003 so yeah I
think it was like I think I was like
right around there maybe 2004 even
Maidan right in there but it was right
you know where she was still very much
here a lot you know she would come in
every every Sunday and Monday not not
every one but almost every Sunday Monday
yeah at least one of those days and then
everyone would just get panicked
everywhere panic and just
scatter you're like okay time to go on
because you got nothing to lose yeah if
you're new you got nothing to lose
oh yeah I mean I've talked about it
before on the podcast but it's uh like I
got past because everyone else who was
supposed to go up before me suddenly
disappeared then it was like oh I can't
find anyone else here next and then I
was just showcasing for my my job and
then she passed me and I was awful I
just remember being like why would she
pass me because they said it's like
funny and it's like and when you've been
here for a while it's like like I think
my favorite my favorite Comedy Store
moment if I have like a favorite comment
or a moment it's like one night I was
here I had a late-night spot it was like
12:15 or 12:30 on a Saturday night and I
was following Whitney Cummings
and this this was a few years back and
so I'm sitting there and I think Chris
Rock had stopped in and I want to say it
wasn't Chappell but it was someone else
like that had stopped in earlier so now
it's like 12:45 it's late Whitney's up
and I'm like [ __ ] you know in the room
has kind of pretty much thinned
anticipated yeah and then all of a
sudden the room starts getting busier
and busier and busier and there's people
starting to crowd in and there's more
people coming in and it keeps getting
busier and busier people are kind of
talking and everything and I was sitting
in Mitzi's seat in the back and I mean
and it really fills in like all of a
sudden this [ __ ] room is packed and I
turn and look to my right and it's
[ __ ] Robin Williams oh and I was like
holy [ __ ] and so Whitney brings up Robin
Williams Robin goes up does like half an
hour he's basically there to make amends
for he just got out of rehab I was there
to make amends to the Comedy Store I
don't know how that happened yeah
because he he did some benefit and he
was like it doesn't even remember being
here you know it was like [ __ ] up or
something yeah so he does that and then
he he brings in and he goes off stage I
go up the crowd starts to leave and I go
were you guys going
Michael Bill Cosby's in the parking lot
and everyone laughed when that was still
a viable possibility that he's not in
the parking lot the same five minutes
five minutes before you got to go on
okay but it was like one of those night
and then I had like this amazing scent
and it was like that was what to me the
comedy snow now it's busy all the
[ __ ] time except when I go on my late
night shift you know we got here and it
was packed right now the both of us are
going back-to-back tonight and we'll be
in front of 12 people not I'll be
thrilled I'm sorry buddy I'm at the
point now where I'm reserved - it's like
I just need to go work on [ __ ] so I'm
gonna go work on [ __ ] yeah because this
is not where we make our money we make
our money elsewhere clearly your Playboy
comedy show in Vegas was a lot of fun it
was the first time I ever featured and
then Paul asked to both of us me and the
headliners I hate you guys want us to
switch and the headliner is like listen
I know I'm not doing well after all but
I'm not switching so yeah thanks for
being on man do you think we're anything
you want at court McGowan or you can
just go to court McGowan calm it's got
my Instagram and my Twitter we're gonna
record your set whatever yeah let's just
hope that it's recorded this time you
guys the listeners are missing out on
epic dave taylor conversation that is we
just really ghost we will bring him back
I have a feeling that it didn't record
because Tommy's right the building
doesn't like this I'm white trash she's
the white trash one so if you can please
subscribe leave us comments
yeah good or bad we don't care yeah
sorry we didn't have one last week but
we will figure it out yeah we're getting
we're getting there guys we're we're not
we have a millennial that's running [ __ ]
over there and he shows are you
considered a millennial hi I am 27 I
believe I am oh yeah that's a millennial
for sure he's a he's a elderly 27 I
don't look at the beard the way you
carry yourself like an angry 35 year
it's exactly right I wouldn't say that I
would just say that you're very slow to
the punch and everything simply wow I
played softball today and I am very fast
you get any hit yes I did okay like what
single I got a double really no homerun
because of an error no you play softball
I'm not bad so I have seen you play you
haven't always I have a bully it's my
new thing I'm gonna be a bully I want to
call my first comedy special American
bully just to push the idea okay well
but I'm not a kanay I don't want people
to get confused and think that I am a
filthy icicle chuckers and we need them
in this country all right come to the
Comedy Store check out a show follow
Illinois and I online as well our
Twitter and all the good stuff my face
take the Comedy Store lawyer always
tells me you know it's high key you
could be for virtual reality what Dane
Cook was for myspace
I don't know what that means but check
it out sounds like your careers in good
hands dude I'm gonna be so [ __ ]
famous by 2035
can't wait yeah I'm hoping not to be
alive by that I won't be diabetes will
strike me before my things to live for
alright thanks for listening guys thanks
back bye
[Applause]
you
[Music]